toujours les hommes préfèrent les
blondes est ce que les blondes préfère
les noirs il faut demander aux glandes
de faire savoir quelque chose quand même
non mais je pense que c'est comme tout
phénomène de contraste il ya une
attirance ces collisions invitons et 1
et les dégâts ton c'est vrai il s'attire
est donc c'était des choses comme ça je
pense plus que ces cds mitzach lèvres un
hit du prix chez moi du cliché
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que moi j'adore
les italiens sont beaucoup plus brune
frère les norvégiennes halloween ou de
fans dans ta vie c'est celle à qui tu es
fait deux enfants est une styliste et on
a fait deux enfants était d'accord ah
oui c'est une styliste une styliste
belge qui vit à bruxelles elle dit
quelques kilomètres de beauxis et
m'accompagne depuis une dizaine d'années
oui c'est une affaire qui dure six mois
disons que je suis un mec qui croient
aux gens comme les gens pensent que la
tension est forte de l'amour c'est une
fille que j'ai rencontrés quand je
trouvais dans des bars ou des lampes des
lombards et de la tête et le plongeur
oui quand j'étais plongera et on
s'entend très bien
je pense que ça durera encore mais quand
tu vas chez chopin chez tes parents
abidjan en côte d'ivoire
comment est ce que ta famille reçoit le
fait que débarque là bas avec une
blanche cela pose aussi des problèmes
n'ont peut-être plus là disons que c'est
vrai que de mon côté c'était il y avait
plus de problèmes que de son côté gilles
c'est là-bas que c'est le plus dur oui
là-bas c'est très dur il faut dire que
ma mère n'étant pas les traits way et
donc elle est encore plus dense en
commerçant car en fait ils sont
commerçants et certaines choses qu'elle
a du mal à comprendre et
maintenant le fait d'avoir deux enfants
au soleil annoncé qu' il faut qu'elles
soient testées convertisse à l'islam
alors on a vu tout l'été dans toute la
presse à cause du film de gérard oury
oui très bonnes idées ont fusé aimerait
bien avoir le compte le star le prendre
en compte deux stars avec sabine azéma
savait trop envie date mais c'est vrai
que le projet de gérard c'était pour ses
magnifiques parce que c'était vraiment
d'abord au départ le projet a été
proposé à michel et de 9 et celle c'est
une amie et celle blanc michel blanc et
après on vous voit alors et pourquoi pas
la preuve c'est que j'ai fait le pli
mons et les titres et très bien entendu
et je crois que ce serait très très
grand suis quand on dit de toi que tu es
le dis merci français ça te fait quoi à
ton avis
c'est flatteur oui bonjour moi ah bon
non pourquoi
parce que j'aimerais bien que king et
les journalistes qui puisse dire à eddie
murphy qu'il ne savait pas de vous
coller en fait cet acabit oui j'ai mis
deux parce que ça me plaisait jonças de
rajouter des c kom sa ville c'est comme
princess erika oui parce que ces ricains
jdir lionax assez implanté à l'idée
blanc vient de faire un peu mal non sa
valeur c'était blanc frime c'est un plan
plus tôt pour voir un peu où en était
cette société occidentale pensée dans
ses rapports avec les colonies mais moi
ça me plaisait bien vrai alors tu aimes
pas quand on dit blake toi parce que tu
dis que c'est une façon je crois que
blague c'est un terme usité sévèrement
importé des états unis je crois c'est
une façon de masquer les choses c'est
pas juste apporter un petit jeu par
hasard pour apporter un extrait d'une
définition du mot [ __ ] way qui était
dans un dictionnaire
le petit larousse édition 1886 et la
définition qu il donne ses hommes femmes
à point noir c'est le nom donné
spécialement aux habitants de certaines
contrées de l'afrique de la guinée la
sénégambie etc qui forment une race
d'hommes noirs inférieur en intelligence
à la race france dit race caucasienne
la coloration de la peau paraît être dû
chez les [ __ ] l influence du climat
c'est une modification acquise qui
deviennent transmissibles est
héréditaire mais il est généralement
reconnu qu'une femme il est trans monter
dans un climat dans notre climat
arrivera à la couleur blanche après
quelques générations et sans mélange de
races qui voit un pan du rebond c'est
insensé
ça n'a pas de longtemps il ya un peu
plus d'un siècle
oui et c'est vrai que je préfère
aujourd'hui le mot [ __ ] ça tout dépend
de comment c'est utilisé dans quel
contexte dans quelle situation
une façon sympathique qui peuvent faire
mais oui je vous fait rire aigre parce
que même des gens comme aimé césaire des
gens comme la new york était le chantre
de la négritude et je vois pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui on est francophone et il ya
des mots qui existent pour appeler les
races je vois pas pourquoi on va le
chercher des mots américain
je n'ai rien contre les alors quand je
me retrouve aux états unis je dirais
blacks
je suis en france je m'enfermais et
cette mode des [ __ ] good par exemple
tu en penses quoi tout ça car le 14
juillet avec des blagues qui sait non
mais je sais c'est bien un moment je
veux dire comme
comme tout mode ya une fin et il faut
pouvoir aller au delà de la moi par
exemple tu tour entre carlton en 88
quand était à cannes pour pour chocolat
et que le mec il ya du baston à l'entrée
tu réagis comment s'est le mieux serait
houssaye
aussi la haine c'est même pas la haine
c'est une sorte de déception de
déception d'une civilisation d'une
société qui m'a appris des choses qui
appose des choses à ma race à ma culture
dont je suis l éditeur comme ça et de
voir que en fait j'ai été berné
en fait j'ai été berné par des gens qui
ne sont pas eux-mêmes fort à l'intérieur
et aujourd'hui quand on n'est pas fort à
l'intérieur je crois qu'on a appelé à
disparaître
oui on devient agressif et je crois
qu'il faut pas répondre par
l'agressivité parce que moi je les fais
il ya 15 ans quand j'étais à paris ne
sera pas résolu les problèmes et noir ni
même le problème
je crois qu'il faut passer outre sa et
c'est bizarre parce que tu me parles de
la mode
c'est vrai que quand je marche dans
paris on se mange des pubs et qui me
dont personne n'en parle ne parle début
du match ou de colloques benetton il y
en a eu en particulier qu'il fallait
noir qui allaitent avec et noir et blanc
dont on ne voit pas le visage de la
femme je trouve que c'est carrément
abjecte comme comme publicité je veux
dire si c'est indécent c'est indécent ce
n'est même pas digne de ces sociétés là
tu vas retourner un jour là bas c'est un
c'est une utopie ouï dire c'est l'idée
du retour et quelque chose je crois qui
a longtemps fait défaut en tout cas fait
beaucoup de mal
la communauté noire africaine qui
s'expatrient qui est venu en europe
puisque tout le temps les gens même
quand ils veulent eux ils voulaient pas
se l'avouer si tu veux il se disait
qu'ils vont rentrer qui vont rentrer ce
qui fait qu'il ne pouvait pas vivre non
convenablement là où il est et je crois
que c'est un danger de vouloir à tout
prix rentrer il faudrait bien là où on
est un petit tour moi je suis une les
groupes politiques
il ya des [ __ ] africain il ya des
[ __ ] américain
moi je suis négropolitain
barbelivien on t'appelle monsieur tube
ouais ça l'a écrit combien aboyant la
presse ça arrive
non c'est pas ce que c'est que de faire
un tube c'est très trop facile parce que
j'ai dû écrire le 2000 chansons dans ma
vie et il y en a trente qu'on connaît
vraiment 20t créé le mouv lit pour
johnny c'est bien ça ouais il ya dix ans
elle mobilise c'est une belle chanson
c'est vrai que tu l'as fait en dix
minutes celle-là 25 minutes 25 minutes
tu penses quoi tu qui a fait johnny
hallyday crda gillet et david l'avenir à
grasse et un bel album
non non il risque tout le monde
maintenant je dit pas du bien tout le
monde mais c'est d'abord moi j'adore
johnny hallyday j'avais regardé gilles
tu me fera pas dire du mal ni de l'un ni
de l'autre
et je trouve que c'est un beau discours
par contre il ya un truc de toi qui est
absolument insupportable en ce moment tu
le sais si je te survivrai non moi je
trouve pas non c'est son client
maintenant si ça c'est pas mon client
non non c'est pas pour ça que je dis ça
et julien clerc et a déçu tu dis par
rapport à ce qu'il faisait au début avec
maurice vallet avec roda gil public
aujourd'hui quand on entend la fille aux
bas nylon c'est pas comme qu'on
l'entende
la cavalerie way out à lui ça mais parce
que je sois né un immense fan de julien
c'est pour ça sur moi j'ai tellement
aimé ivanovic sous les fleurs des gares
où la petite sorcière malades ou yann et
les dauphins que je trouve que ça s'est
un peu banalisé dans les murs quoi
encore que bon il fait des trucs avec
d'abedi qui était très très beau mais
moi j'étais un
un grand fan de la combinaison maurice
vallet et roda gil rui revenir à cette
combinaison en bas mais moi je serais
lui je l'aurais jamais quitté même je
veux dire à moi si j'avais eu en tant
qu'interprète des auteurs comme etienne
et maurice quoi je continuerai de
chanter leurs textes sur les lalanne pas
trop non plus hein tu as dit que c'était
un apprenti léo ferré ouais ouais t'es
bien renseigné j'ai dit ça un jour d'or
dans télé 7 jours mais c'était un peu
[ __ ] pour lui mais après j'ai
rencontré le type il est plutôt sympa
francis lalanne mai mais tous côtés tu
fais gaffe il frappe en plus ouais bah
ouais ouais il a frappé par yvette
rappelle m il s'est pas défendu mais il
fait pas non mais se trouve le côté un
peu peace and love avec le public moi ça
me gonfle un peu vrai comment tu fais
pour écrire des chansons de faire des
trucs par exemple la mer les lilas c'est
des trucs qui reviennent souvent dans
des chansons dans way celi la maison
chanson serait ouais c'est pas des trucs
c'est plutôt des tic c'est à la limite
c'est plutôt des mauvais trucks a certes
des choses énervant c'est à toi pour te
fait remarquer en 10 mai mais moi je
m'en rends pas compte il ya des gens qui
me tient j'étais sûr que c'était toi
parce qu'il y avait dit la maison quais
de gares et trains de nuit
tu dis que tu mets à la place de
l'interprète je rentre complètement tu
te moules dans l'imaginaire de
l'interprète h et ça s'est fait assez
compréhensifs
ouais c'est grande rue à par exemple à
l'interprète comme jean pierre françois
tu te moules dans l'imaginaire de
chantier un procès s'ouvrira devant ces
murs avec jean pierre françois ça mais
non mais c'est vrai par exemple qui va
le découvrir dans le nouveau 45,6 il ya
la novaya nano du temps encore un
troisième nom mais c'est il faut essayer
enfin pour les gens qui n'écrivent pas
moi j'essaie qui me racontent leur vie
leur histoire essayer de deviner ce qui
traduirait s'il écrivait des chansons
c'est ça qui est intéressant je les fais
pour patricia kaas et tu vois ça s'est
bien passé
très bien mais alors est-ce que c'est à
force de te moulé comme salon des
imaginaires de celui de jean pierre
françois qui s'est décidé de faire une
carrière solo parce que ton pouvait plus
parce que tu d'un seul coup tu non pas
du tout c'est maintenant que j'aime bien
je cherche pas vraiment à faire une
carrière solo mais j'aime bien
enregistrer des disques
j'en enregistre depuis 15 ans maintenant
un peu plus de 15 ans j'aime bien ça
elle a fait quelques bidons les soixante
dix a commencé à marcher avec elle elle
cas de 800 mille huit cent mille disques
mais je l'ait pas fait exprès non plus
puisqu'il le solide après j'en ai vendu
38 tu as ça veut rien dire
une punchline test mais après c'est
beaucoup dire mental elle subir qua non
jean pierre françois je te survivrai
j'ai fait une grande découverte en
lisant son livre c'est que parmi les
superstars qui entoure et andy warhol et
ab une française et c'était toi
bon
alors au départ tu fais partie d'une
bonne bourgeoisie grenobloise quoi des
gens plutôt riche c'est quoi
oh mon père était ingénieur pas ce qu'on
peut appeler industriels
puis l'on pense assez difficile malgré
tout c'est à dire la petite fille un peu
sauvage comme ça au vivier d'une famille
bourgeoise tu étais dans une sorte de
courant on peut dire non de courant à
l'autre parce qu'on m'a jetée d'une
porte à l'autre
et chaque fois je me rebelle est
davantage et fait l'amour ça s'est mal
terminée maison de correction un
exorcisme situé d'exorciser enfin on y
viendra parce qu'à la fin du livre une
sorte d'exorcisme et j'étais réellement
exorciser ses rares enfin à exorciser
avec leur propre terme c'est à dire
qu'on vous met le lobby il ya une prière
spéciale aura fait par un prêtre je sais
pas comment se passent les autres
exercices
en tout cas ça n'a pas marché où j'ai
prétendu tel fallait marcher par valeur
d' avoir marché pendant les la suite de
google une première expérience sexuelle
assez
c'est difficile près c'était presque un
viol d'une certaine façon que tu
racontes savant dans le bouquin pas
sexuellement ça tape à bloquer pour la
suite
non peut-être débloquer d'appro
débloquer peut-être on peut dire mais ça
va c'est a pas réellement bloqués si
jamais ce que ça fait très difficile
d'établir les causes et les effets
peut-être que à ce moment là on perd un
certain respect de la chose ou alors on
tour by est très difficile de savoir
il faut que je crois 50 ans pour arriver
à tirer les conclusions
alors un jour des parents décident de
t'envoyer en revue et ça ta soeur habite
est en fait tu crois que tu la joues pas
tu rangé des voitures en arrivant là bas
mais c'est terry parce que tu arrives là
bas tu n'as qu'une envie c'est conquérir
le monde de l'art tu deviens un copines
ou amis ou amants avec des aliments par
manque pas vraiment parce qu'un jour tu
es avec lui voilà qu'avec une langouste
votre d'elle c'était sa méthode d'alien
de faire l'amour si je n'avais plus loin
non avec dali elle sait jamais de
pénétration mais plutôt d'imagination
très vite dalit présenta à warhol qui à
l'époque inconnue en pleurs
mais est tout de suite j'ai été fasciné
par le caractère parce que c'était un
homme vraiment un espèce d'extra
terrestres il ne parlait pas comme les
ont d'abord il parlait à peine ou s'il
parlait il avait une espèce de voix
devant trilogue et tout ce qu'il disait
c'est tellement à la fois génial ou
idiote hickman savez jamais qui s'était
d'ailleurs par warhol c'est un paradoxe
extraordinaire leur première rencontre
avec warhol tu te sautent dessus tu es
quand même un peu enfin comme on dit
vulgairement découvrir quel était cet
homme ou si vraiment c'était un homme
d'ailleurs l'expérience a été assez
facile et rend dans ce sens que comme je
le raconte que son corps et d'effroi et
devenait de plus en plus glacial enfin
c'est juste un repas s'est libéré de
soit complètement et oui ma faille quand
même il s'est d'abord refroidi
énormément j'ai cru qu'il allait de
tourner à la glace il a perdu un peu
zappé rue il a plus ou moins connu sa
période qui quand même resté accroché
par un bouton pression qui lui est fait
imprégné dans craindre que j'ai quand
même pas un homme ordinaire
trois faits devenu une superstar de la
factrice tekki les autres avec les
vivants avaient james ross
il y avait entre deux super stars qui or
qui avaient brigitte bourjade folk
d'après paul et interviews oui qui était
la fille de brigitte beuls et de
monsieur berline qu'était le président
de la société instant et aveo lt il veut
neymar et les tables principal lequel
quelques heures aussi toi on a décidé
encore départ tu sais pas comment tu
appelé à résister il y avait polyester
il y avait une autre dame et
ultraviolets pourquoi vous avez choisi
le violet avec warhol déjà trouvé que
c'était beaucoup plus futuristic
beaucoup plus original beaucoup plus
féminin ultra c'est mieux que maria
sofia
et violet c'était très artistique la
couleur
j'ai toujours été un peu au delà ultra
but et ça veut dire
au delà du spectre la lumière
pour espérer c'est bien vous à partir de
là c'était lui enlever comme ce soir
m'enfin avec peut-être des tenues un peu
différent oui on s'était beaucoup fait
violer les cheveux violé les atouts et
les lèvres tu avais dans ton sac comme
c'est un petit morceau de betteraves
dont il fait toujours mal d'être à
l'affût jours s'est passé à la non pas
chanter c'est vrai que moi j'ai lu un
truc quand on coupe un qui va
complètement fasciné c'est que tu te
mettais à la droite de warhol comme ça
sur les photos dans la légende des
photos dans les journaux ton nom mais
avant celui tout le monde ici j'ai
jamais pensé la factory tu auras tu
donne effectivement un récit comme ça
qu'est si quotidien la factory ya
d'abord le sexe alors l'homosexualité à
tout crin c'est ça ma choquer la petite
française que tu étais non ça m'a l'air
non parce que c'est d'abord une époque
de révolution aux états unis et je suis
parti pour faire un peu donc c'était
tout à fait normal
et à l'époque les homosexuels c'était
parfait car ils vous dérangez pas ils
vous en prendre aux français pas donc
c'est non ce jeudi synaip quand même
c'est bizarre un mélange et matt a fallu
plusieurs années ont beau
me rendre
sexuelle bizarre non pourtant il ce
n'est pas oui m'enfin on se rend compte
qu'il était peut-être que ça
croyable et homosexualité sadomasochisme
bondage sans arrêt enfin les gêner et
puis alors départ tout de formidables
sans arrêt dans les landes dans les labo
photo et auquel warhol participer pas
d'ailleurs parce qu'un jour tu cite une
phrase en tongs ou kindu serre ondine
qui dit on la vire est là partout parce
que vraiment il les faisait rien quoi
non mais les peintres par définition
sont des voyeurs
c'est l'oeil qui est l'organe leur
diplôme au regard d ivoire ont
d'ailleurs à berck on touche ici mais
vont toucher enfin le bras même sa
jaquette il aider ceux qui se bougent et
tout de suite très peur des rapports
lyonnais je crois est pensé que c'était
une perte de temps
parce que pour ce qu'il voulait faire
qui l'intéressé c'est de faire sa marque
sur la culture américaine
les rapports ça prend un temps fou
il est arrivé il ya même de la zoophilie
à un moment il est tout sur un cheval
il rappelait aussi pour le besoin du fil
dans les films et pas les uns peut se
dépasser et il fallait comme il n'est
pas d'histoires que tout est improvisé
il fallait faire de plus en plus de plus
en plus fort la drogue oui mais ça dans
les années 60 c'était devenu d'abord
c'est une longue histoire la drogue a
toujours existé non moi j'ai eu très
très peur la drogue gâteau dali et puis
tu sais tu as faim non mais tu dis à
papa
moi non j'ai perdu mon sac j'ai perdu
mes clés je me suis dit c'est pas
pourquoi remplacer bourgeois faire sans
ça on a besoin de ces clés pour rentrer
chez eux les agents ont alors mis le
tout ça warhol quand un petit travail
parce que mon mariage est techniquement
joey nuit fait travailler tout le monde
alors la boîte de soupe campbell c'est
qui qu'a eu l'idée parce que là les
grandes discussions là-dessus pour
savoir qu'est ce qui a évité cette boîte
de soupe d'état de chants populaires de
marcel duchamp bâtiment où il apprit
importe vous ayez déjà bon sens warhol
sort du champ droit
mais quand même voir
le conduisait toujours son rôle dit paul
et demandé à tout le monde qu est ce que
je dois faire
dites moi qu'est ce que je dois pas très
intelligent et alors si la majorité des
gens lui disais bon des combats de
concert c'est ce qu'il a fait si trois
personnes visées ton portrait il ne
faisait pas et voulait il n'a jamais dit
je voudrais faire un chef-d'oeuvre
il voulait pas la préoccupation des gens
ce que les gens voulaient c'est comme ça
qu'il a réussie qui a été acceptée
disons presque instantanément
il a fait les fameuses fleurs et tu es
là quand il passe est un as peur alors
ses fleurs toi une 64e' temps cran
devant un tableau représentant ces
fleurs mille dollars et leur vente on
sait par quelle eau avec le danois
physique oui ils vont me dollars dès
maintenant sa voix millions de dollars
de m
toujours ces tableaux génie
je n'aime pas ce que je fais une partie
en assurant une passion avant proches
sont pas le dire à la risée des films et
deux sortes de films en gros quoi il ya
les styles comme s'appellent si tu vois
quelqu'un dormir pendant huit heures au
moulin de versailles puis à d'autres
films et maurice et comme trash flèche
la septième plus mis en scène quand même
commercial alors qu'il s'est quand même
fait du pognon et accessible c'était
fortis les superstars n'était payé quoi
qu'ils étaient super star à 20 dollars
par jour rien de rien de rien on m'a dit
l'autre jour je capitaliser sur bois
rouge était la veuve joyeuse jamais
gagné mais il avait le don de nous
amuser on s'amuse et on n'était pas du
tout nos forces et d'être là et comment
jouer nous mêmes
enfin c'était très intéressant même
selon psychologique vous voulez un peu
posséder à la sortie quand même parce
que lui il s'en est non
ce n'est que lui avait un plan un plan
d'action nous en avait parlé il était là
pour pour le pour l'amusement
au moment et lui lui savait ce qu'il
voulait enfin je lui reproche pour et 1
contre
le joliettain qui tombe par la fenêtre
et il dit c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas
une caméra pour le film l'école oui
enfin si quelqu'un doit mourir
pourquoi ne pas le filmer peut-être
c'était ça l'objectif
tu penses comme truman capote que c'est
un sphinx en secret au absolument
c'est une très belle phrase très bon
et alors un jour tu craques complètement
c'est la crise
c'est terrible une catharsis et tu passe
comme ça je sais pas combien de temps
dont on lit ces seuils ne tue si on veut
de soigner tu veux pas tu dis que tu te
sois ira tout seul c'était un cétacé
assez poignant quand prendre quand on
lit sans qu'aucun et là je crois que
c'est l'exorcisme qui réussissent et une
fois par an contrairement au premier un
moment tu peux avoir tes parents tu
arrives dans le midi évidemment quand on
sort de la factory de chez warhol et
quand débarque dans une maison bien
bourgeoise bien française
ça veut dire mais ça fait du bien quand
on le lit aussi c'est que j'y suis allé
pour presque leur dire au revoir
je pensais que j'allais mourir et c'est
eux qui m'ont ressuscité est retourné
vers la religion catholique et roman la
non non non non non non pas la religion
catholique mais vert
le christianisme on american and
religion comme tu sais plus tôt
évangéliques on lit les rôles étudie les
écritures français alors tu veux tu dis
ultraconservateur c'est vrai oui oui je
me souviens que c'est à dire que je
pense que la lame salvation que le salut
ne peut vraiment être trouvé quatre
avaient une liste de morale sami quand
même temps contremaître de tout ça
au moins quinze ans je dirais je sais
pas si j'en suis complètement remis
qu'est ce que tu penses
je pense que tu sais faire
et ouais si emir kusturica lion d'or
pour te souviens-tu de libelles palme
d'or pour papa est en voyage d'affaires
et meilleur réalisateur ken 89 pour le
temps des gitans une nacelle et fight
when you got the form i can't you left
to sarajevo et new sail nicosia de
friends and her back to help him to 8h
et 10h voici trois hits noah chaye yo et
apprêtée jeu
[Musique]
et tous ces retraités problème de taille
mini propose aux machos refused to work
elle soit la vieille toulouse au sol
m
camille coming out magazine newspaper
pour l'express politicards story gipsy
kings
un show de scripts ou david portenard
m
draka
mais comme zen spa et david poot nav
jazz be just a game et gamestation soir
alors tu sors un double album 23 titre
s'appelle succès fou avec l'éthique du
début c'est-à-dire aline les
marionnettes avec les l'époque des
albums les mots bleus señorita tout est
bien ce dans ce disque à part la
pochette lafayette c'est risqué ouais
mais bon on aime on ne prend pas un
risque pour les petits picasso c'est un
truc et c'est aussi un peu
un peu vite fais pas c'est parce
qu'annulant le disque enfin tant que
c'est que ça tu t'en fous toi et un an
je me comprend une jupe d'accord mais
bon c'est fait ouais antennes et à
juvisy sur orge ton père était
installateur de chauffage central ouais
il est étalé sur la côte concepteur
[Musique]
si la grande époque de la côte d'azur au
snack 64 ouais c'est avec une chanson
décommandé
qui s'appelait à washington ouais je
faisais ça que je faisais c'était pas
connu je sais dans les boîtes de nuit
d'abord et après je sais dans l'est dans
les pizzas est-ce que c'était pas connu
j'écoutais ces gens là où est ce un
traditionnel c'est que ces gens-là sur
fun radio carolin et ses sorties en
france avant après et voit quand je
chantais ça je disais que c'était moi
qui la composent est confirmée mais bon
c'est super
moi je sais lepage avec un ordre alors
en 1964 tu vas agents les peintures
rencontre une fille qui s'appelle aline
la tanovic qui était assistante d'un
estomac tôt et qui veut toujours
d'écouter justement chanté the rising
sun et l'aide après pour elle tu as
composé à lille 65 tube énorme
il ya eu un procès quand même avec jacky
molard parce que ça ressemble à une
chanson qui régit sortie en 62 capes est
largement acceptée la romance mais ça
ressemblait vraiment ça ressemblait pas
mal assimilé un effectivement bon et un
procès je les perds du blocage du carroi
5 kg car ses idées recettes et tout ça
pour rigoler du tout là ouais ouais mais
bon j'avais 20 ans je dis rien c'est
juste je suis fait partie des hommes qui
par leur roulotte et à moissac allait me
ranger ma vie à l'an 66 staff et les
marionnettes 67 monsieur le professeur
en fait avait la haine des tuques en
fait c'est pas du tout ce que tu voulais
faire toi tu voulais faire du rock qui
vous l'êtes dany baby à l'ailé
vigan ouais mais c'est moi j'aurais pu
faire du blues parce que si tu veux ce
qui m'a bercé dans les années 60 c'est
quand même au curling kings climat repos
au cje en arrière est-ce que c'est pas
le fait d'être devenu un tube heures
français par rapport au bout ce que tu
voulais chanter
quitte à donner une espèce de ben de toi
et qui t'a amené à faire toutes ces
conneries parce qu'on a fait après des
conneries là partir de 67 non crochet
mullinder non c'est l'image que j'ai
donné c'est pas de ma faute et je
comprends qu'en fait on fait une fesse
de brest un garde est nul c'est vrai que
bonjour un gala par jour
le pognon qui arrivait comme pas
possible tu t'achètes un flat avec
terrasse dans le xvième les bolides
enfin tu es parti dans un drôle de trip
un peu un peu pop star ses règles en
plus la défense et l'alcool devant une
bière les connaît paris en comment la
défense s'attache à s'arrêter ou h ouais
donc effectivement je pouvais pas
beaucoup ce qui est un peu par la suite
vous empêcher de co2 écrire oui et quand
au bout d'un an et demi deux ans je suis
là c'est grave l'ajax ne sache pas
trouvé une idée j'ai balayé parce qu'on
69 tu t'es retrouvé ruiné disparu un
moment tel trou noir oui 68 60 60 ou
untel j'étais bien j'étais loin de tous
âges étaient dans un rêve j'étais revenu
dans - elle est intervenue en 73 c'était
gymnastique je me faire pardonner je
fais de la peinture je suis sage et là
ça fait tous ses albums
jean michel jarre est atteint c'est une
époque formidable ça soulève depuis
longtemps il se trouve moi c'est a
desservi finalement c'est avait servi à
ouais mais tous les trouvant à dire que
j'étais jusqu'aujourd'hui tous les
tournois de laisser des trous noirs
comment que je que je provoque aller
vite parce que j'ai besoin de ça moi je
peux pas toujours
il faut que je m'arrête
non non pas parce que sinon ça commence
à être aimé par la critique à ce moment
là et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui des
gens comme eux comme bâillon par exemple
10 ya un côté yéyé pourri chez
christophe un peu mencé bonne image
quand même temps que gérard manset
ils trouvent ça allait à bail en moi il
était gouverneur
je pense que comme un non mais je pense
qu'il est quand même dans un à l'écart
de tout ça je mets de côté y est pourri
c'est vrai un peu quand même dans ses
albums
ouais jeu sournois un peu bizarre mais
bon si tu veux le problème de ces albums
quand j'analyse aujourd'hui par rapport
à l'album est en train de faire c'est un
peu le texte est ce que tu entends bon
je fais un truc tôt merci tu es devenu
au mariage et là j'en suis fier parce
que c'est toi tu l'as mis dans la
vieille ville va et vient sur ben oui
parce que c'est tout ce que j'aime j'ai
écrit un truc tu vois c'est un problème
mental et señorita les mange loïc
comment moi je suis un écrivain belge
s'apprête à être construit veut dire on
va peut-être me prendre pour un narguilé
jeudi même si elle a des mots qui
m'écoutent ouah je peux écrire des trucs
méfiance
gbagbo soir alors après cannes
roland garros en même temps les rolling
stones avant les vacances une
focalisation médiatique énorme sur andy
warhol et toi mieux de tout ça tu arrivé
qu'un bouquin chez oubliée qui dit andy
warhol n'est pas à croire
guy andy warhol est un grand
publicitaire la pub c'est pas du grand
art donc warhol n'est pas un grand arc
et ça c'est le raisonnement de base du
vivre
cqfd alors tu expliques que andy warhol
est un grand publicitaire pour commencer
et tu parles du concept
je vois ma vie qui choisit ses sujets
comme finalement choisi des concepts
dans la pub quoi ah bah oui parce que
bon comme marlboro ses traits d'école
comme à l'euro près c'est ouest de la
france pour maintenir que la puce et
récupérer ce qui peut naître il ya une
tuque pour ricard l'a dernièrement c'est
juste après le grand bleu jusqu'à ce que
les hommes funèbres et dans l'ouest dont
il faut bien savoir que la musique de
margaux roque est connu comme gilles
d'amours hausse et la musique de sept
mercenaires et d'en cas de moins de la
rolls qu'est ce que c'est lui qui
récupère comme la glace et le premier
point soit tu dis
son style pictural c'est la direction
artistique bah oui parce que si la photo
est pas de lui si le cadre est chez le
plus ouvert possible c'est surprise
s'éclate sur les couleurs alors il fait
c'est vrai il fait des trucs plus ou
moins bien en restant réussi une couleur
et mais quoi qu au début non au bulgare
des couleurs ainsi certains vaisseaux
parce que on en fait une partie dont dix
aux turcs ou francine génial il a fait
de campbell soup la joconde lycée
la sortie comme des sous elle date de 98
et c'est ce que je veux dire c'est que
ça c'est un package magnifique 98 1886
19e siècle bon sur c'est déjà un must
il arrive en cinq ans 60,2 et puis tenté
il t'en fais ça dans le jeu compte de
ces raids
je dis non dit le mec avait fait ça les
a plus fort toujours l'écran
publicitaire tu dis son discours c'est
des slogans c'est une suite de slogans
en fait c'est pas discours sur la
peinture
non je ne suis pas dans son cas c'est
qu'il a quatre saints slogans parmi
lesquels bon jeu densité 1 parce qu'ils
libèrent connus mais les tripes
il est très bon elle a été très bon son
histoire de ses plus beaux à part des
ses balles donald dubois florence
nationale que plus bunker sein d'adp
pékin et moscou encore rien de beau
c'est très bon surtout lorsque ces faux
maintenant mais c'est pas grave mais il
est tellement est et ce qui est fort
dans son affaire c'est que n'importe
quelle phrase de warhol j'aime l'ennui
je voudrais être une machine le truc sur
mcdonald's s'applique à n'importe quel
tableau et donc ça marche bien on peut
légende et n'importe quelle photo
choisie par warhol mise en scène par dix
ont dirigé artistiquement pas revoir aux
diacres artistique et légendées par andy
warhol rédacteurs quand tu es dans la
pub et ça marche très bien quand tu
démontres assez clairement que warhol
est un grand publicitaire
mais qu'est ce qui te fait dire que la
pub ce n'est pas de l'art je me souviens
les déclarations jack lang qui disait
dans globe la pub j'adore ces deux là
je vais le dire en français c'est zéro
sont déçus que je suis déçu quand pensez
vous encore très bien parce que toute
cette idéologie du du tout et de large
je suis contre et je pense que ce point
de vue là que ma cible c'est autant les
publicitaires qui se prendrait pour les
artistes d'hier c'est le problème de
goutelas quand il a fait son expulsion
marseille qui était la risée total alors
que c'était bien quand il faisait quand
vous excusez moi et c'est le même site
que j'ai sur l'art contemporain dit
avant gardiste dans les deux cas ils
sont persuadés que que c'est l'idée qui
compte et que le reste n'a pas
d'importance ont plutôt laissé à
d'autres
tous s'y sont ils pensent tous que
l'idée du savoir-faire et 2ème siècle et
non je ne suis pas d'accord je suis pour
l'art moderne contre la faim en pâtira
pas avec le dos de la cuillère tu dis
les tables voirol cd mauvaise photocopie
couleur exposé dans une maison des
jeunes et de la culture c'est sérieux
vent non ça veut dire que dans vos
études faute cancer produisait quand
s'est produit jeudi que cette frange ya
ce que la a6 n'aura pas pas quand cancer
produit dans un catalogue en impression
que c'est assez fort il en a fait sa
centralité transcender c'est à dire que
le grain de la photographie surtout je
suis restée l'heure où il a parfaitement
réussi son coup d'envoi la photographie
d'un presque désert de grandes pointures
à son affaire et puis et puis
six mois c'est quand j'ai vu enfin alors
je suis allée parce que l'exposition là
c'est pas toujours qu'il a fait c'est le
moment qu'il est un sénégalais non je
suis allé à düsseldorf et saisir
c'est gênant sinon ce que c'était des
photos d'accidents de voiture fait
valoir horizon thé noir et blanc sur un
fou or alive dans le midi fort pour que
ça dérape aussi donc ça et ça fait
vraiment ça fait mauvais ce qu'au togo
en tout dix ans plus ici te fatigue pas
vraiment parce que faire un symbole avec
campbell soup qui est un must qui était
déjà né avec marie manie chez marie
ninacs est magnifique voilà donc toi tu
dis c'est pas de l'art c'est l'art du
vol
bon c'est pas de la cds et c'est facile
c'est un effet qui sont requis sont
téléphonés franchement c'est vrai que
ses draps c'est vrai qu'une intensité
dans des accidents de voiture et dans
les laits électrique mais bon elle y
était déjà pour la merde sic et électro
alors ça je ne peux pas voir ce côté là
qui dit vrai mais qui perd facile quoi
est-ce que prendront finalement c'est la
photo de cordes bad qu'il a repris qui
est excellent pour c'est le talon de
monroe c'est le talent de korn ban et
puis c'est la ceiba directeur artistique
les gens comprennent bien ce que je veux
dire que j'ai dit c'est quand un tableau
de magritte et d'adjoint de faire la
mise en page pour un livre de philo
alors tu vas le cadre est plus ou moins
bien tu vas être suffisamment habile
dans le choix et tout est un art du soir
mais au fond warhol pour lui consacre à
nouveau disponible on a dit des
conneries sur lui sur on a voulu exagéré
et c'est toujours des mauvais simplement
retour de descendre quelqu'un qui on
commence à calculer tout bon on a voulu
absolument dire qu'il s'entourait mec
qu'il avait un plaisir pervers à les
voir mourir voire à les aider à moorhead
savoir c'est des conneries
avis aider comac non c'est un type
sympathique hyper honnête tout ce qui
peut se payer de l'argent oui je le dis
tout ce qui dit que la sérigraphie c'est
vachement bien parce que la france est
fatiguée qu'elle offrira sur place la
raison et il dit surtout c'est sa plus
grande phrase qui a été toujours mais
entendu d'un service et vous savez pour
comprendre tout ça en ivoire où vous
n'avez qu'à regarder la surface et bat
de mes peintures la surface de mes films
la surface de moi et a rien derrière et
je suis d'accord derrière ils étudient
qui vit sa vie comme une campagne de pub
et c'est vrai que ce que tu racontes en
tout cas c'est quand il arrive à new
york en arrivant de pittsburgh en 49 il
a déjà tout trouvé
parce qu'il fait des reproductions il
envoie les petits portfolio à tout le
monde pour se faire connaître enfin
c'est vrai enfin là il faut être un peu
méchant parce qu il faut dire dans les
années 50 quand il vient il n'est pas
pris comme cognac artistique terre comme
coloriste de quelque chose comme pour
ses terres il est pris comme
illustrateur sert comme un artiste
commercial convertissent cayla dont se
servent les diacres et l'utilisateur
sous le joug le corps manuel qui va
faire auquel il va faire jouer un rôle
dans les années 60
et quand illustrateur il fait moi je dis
il exprime enfin sambre et à enfin ce
sombre est plutôt pour une fois ce sont
vos trucs et son vrai truc c'est quoi
céder
la cocteau cd des trucs à la bird les
super manière répétée tous avant et c
zéro et comme c'est que c'est zéro ça
c'est du chant c'est pareil il arrête
ses illustrations comme du chant arrête
sa peinture 1913 il dit non il faut un
gros coup il faut un bon coup il faut
parce que comme il a horreur pour tous
ces mecs là ils ont horreur d'être jugé
et tout le truc c'est la fuite du
jugement qui est un syndrome disons d'un
certain art de l'idée du champ à buren
klein idazza sait quoi faire pour ne pas
être jugé pour ce que j'ai fait et on va
montrer campbell soup des trucs très
fort de gros mythe marilyn monroe
déchets électriques est comme ça il est
sûr que sa main qu'il faut des volutes à
la cocteau
on la verra jamais on croit l'algérie
l'a jugé et on dirait jamais satisfaits
ne pas être un artiste plutôt perdre
c'est quand même le havre est ce que tu
crois que ce bouquin aura autant de
succès que les mouvements de mode
expliquer aux parents le warhol ouais
non plus combien allez-vous en mode 160
ha ouais je comprends édition de poche
entre ai je toujours soignés et comment
ils sont achetés voyage ou calculer
faire ce qui s'appelait la culture
classique expliqué aux jeunes après les
mouvements de prix appliquées aux
parents elle a great city où je ne
pourrais jamais fait pas c'est que t'es
bon non non c'est vrai c'est vrai au
total look avec ton copain boire on
s'appelle ma vie quand c'est assez drôle
c'est 120 double page blanche
les purs décrit comme ça sur les sujets
l'amour la famille la maison
l'argent on remplit ont rempli les cas
ces sorties pour les cadeaux de fin
d'année
enfin 89 et pour 190 francs band et le
l'auteur le héros le lecteur le lecteur
dans ce nouvel opus problème c'est qu'on
peut pas le vignoble ou pas c'est à dire
que c'est vous n'en sortirons proches
qui exprime la dernière page comme ceci
fait cent vingt 120 douvrais serait
maintenant qu'est ce qui est écrit à
tout à l'heure en rentrant chez toi /
aujourd'hui dans ma vie à la question
serait plutôt est-ce que je vais
sélectionner
on a parlé ensemble
mais bon soir à you still night clubbing
now you see me koubbi breach itno au
rail
j'essaye de me marc ulmann ait fait cela
et accises à dubaï job kfé les et chaud
les it because of you kaysing fumeurs
n'osent pas dire non
et comme ce thème
nakheel gaubert is it shows that one you
m si vous ne connaissez rien j'appelle à
nu soir à deux faces trop un oiseau
roadie to go un masque car tout comme
mignot les acheteurs
vidéo non coiffé d'un prix de
différentes girl the bravery night
asking for t-box toits de cabanes les
lignes des saisies at inc
julie john lennon rose du living with
the japanese coeur magnoac wide
association of sound gardes nature dab
has always son idée initiale et eric non
non
brick by brick in the wall a thing he
did
une guerre du titre
[Musique]
working in ypsilanti dit à nos parents a
living in a truck and bus de choses à
pleigne jones industrial a de la joie
des réseaux big ben et de la mairie il
est très souvent des moddeurs walt
disney sinatra radio agneaux phase c'est
show business people à des aristos
pression d'escale d'origine on chope
le premier mur facebook guen a nazione
would be pop james osterberg tout ou
partie du mythe de acheteurs d'or
chinois zhang fan des soldes
ils n'ont pas exactement d'où teach me
and you started the stooges year one
france by the kings new dawn of war
horse aubry on se barricade
[Musique]
hybrid de sex pistols sommes no fun
groupimo d'einstein vous si vous
nitsuja album de dix albums - produced
by her because you want to know nico
extraits
microsoft et hp m tony de fright because
the boys and interest in your hands
browne you're tout si dièse box office
de fast and uk de sang'' sinatra son nid
comme au stade à taichung hospital
david bowie finish un dîner annuel good
time and the big o négatif de 90 jours
et son permis
c'est de battre bari de gaulle
protective de talent comme aux assauts
de james cameron
rhodia redonne want your hands off you
outre la famine
[Musique]